paralympic games start on august 24th
and run all the way through to september
5th
and this young man is the youngest
member
of the usa paralympic track and field
team
and we say congratulations to making the
team to one of los angeles finest
tokyo paralympic athlete ezra freck here
on the rich eisen show nice to meet you
ezra
nice to meet you as well thank you for
having me congratulations
congrats thank you thank you very much
walk me through your journey here ezra
when did you know you said
where you're like you know what i wanna
i wanna try for the the paralympic
uh team and track and field i'm gonna go
for it walk me through that for you
yeah for sure i uh ever since i was a
little kid growing up uh
sports was a huge part of my life and it
wasn't until i was about eight years old
i began track and field
and then in 2016 i watched
the the rio 2016 paralympics and at that
moment
i told my parents we all sit on the
couch i said i'm gonna make the 2020
tokyo paralympic
team and uh you know that's when i
really put my head down i
i put it on the universe and now five
years later
it would have been four but it got
postponed so five years later
i uh i made that dream a reality so yeah
it's been a wild journey for sure so
you were 11 when you said that about
wanting to play
in the 2020 games is that yeah i was 11
when i said i wanted to make the team
wow so what what's instilled in you to
be an 11 year old with such a lofty goal
and such a
competitive spirit that's right i
it was you know i loved to compete and i
i saw a dream that i i knew i could make
it happen and since it's one of those it
was one of those
moments where you look back and you're
like that was that was that was it that
was where
that was where something took over me
where i knew it was like it was like i
was told like this is what you're you're
meant to do this is where the journey's
meant to go and so i
i watched those games i was inspired
heavily by all the competition and i
said i will be there one day and then
now
grateful for all for the journey but
five years later i am there
what is congenital limb differences ezra
for those
who may not know what is that yeah by a
little bit of
the medical background i was basically i
was born with a left leg
that was curved in towards my waist and
i was born with one finger on my left
hand
and i had a surgery at two and a half
years old and
the doctors removed the curve part of my
left leg
and then transplanted the big toe from
my left leg that was curved in onto my
left hand
so i i went from having one finger on my
left hand having two
so i could pick things up hold things as
a baby and then now i got a stump at two
and a half years old that could fit into
a prosthetic leg much easier
so those are the congenital limb
differences that i had growing up and
the surgeries down
so then your sport is what ezra what do
you got for me
for those who may not know yeah i played
a lot of basketball growing up
basketball is my favorite sport for a
while but
i uh right now i qualified in track and
field so
track and field has been my main sport
for the past four or five years ever
since that moment in 2016 that's where
dragon field took over
i mean unbelievable what's your training
regimen ezra
what is it yeah the training the
training's awesome i mean i i love the
work
me and my coach say you know we're the
hardest workers out there so we
you know now we're in summer we're
putting in two times a day at the track
we have a weightlifting session three to
four times a week we recover well we
train well
we eat well i i basically i say it every
day to my coach i say
i'm willing to sacrifice everything so i
do sacrifice as much as i possibly can
to put myself in the best possible
position going into tokyo do you train
i mean do you sacrifice a teenage life
is that what you're
pretty much referring to i do sacrifice
a teenage life as much as it sucks
you know it's the life that i it's life
that i chose i don't stay out as late
with my friends sometimes i don't go out
on fourth of july i didn't stay i didn't
even go out at night on fourth of july i
came back because i had training the
next morning to
to take ice bath and recover so i do
sacrifice a teenage life in some sense
well i'm a 52 year old man saying you
didn't miss anything on july 4th
don't don't worry about it i mean so um
but you do have the rewards
of of of succeeding at a level
that few people do regardless of how
they were born
ezra so i congratulate you on that as
well as what you've done with angel city
sports what is that
because we see that on the photographs
on the screen of you competing
um that there is a logo on
on your on your i guess gear what what
is that
angel city sports yeah angel city sports
is a non-profit that my family and i
started
to provide sports opportunities for
people with physical disabilities like
myself
in southern california we realized there
was just there was no adaptive sports do
you think you think about it like
someone in a wheelchair they can't just
roll up to the ymca and play pickup
basketball
against all the other stand-up guys and
there's lots of equipment involved and
very few access to sports for people
with physical disabilities so
um we recognized we recognized that gap
and then you know we filled it in
providing a community providing sports
opportunities clinics competitions
uh may all you five years ago back in
2013 we started that
oh no about eight years ago eight years
ago eight years ago in 2013 we started
that
um and uh yeah we provide sports for
people with physical disabilities and
it's it's
you know uh living with the physical
disability is difficult you feel like an
outsider
everywhere you go you don't feel like
you fit in so we provide a place where
where people with physical disabilities
can go where
you know they feel like they're just one
of the guys they feel like they fit in
and actually
being completely able-bodied having all
your limbs
is makes you more different in that type
of scenario when everyone else has a
physical disability as well so
it's uh it's been a blessing to provide
that for the community under 17 high
jump world champion
ezra frack u.s paralympic track and
field member here on the rich eisen show
in advance of the
uh paralympic games that start on august
24th in tokyo
japan have you ever been uh abroad uh in
tokyo is this gonna be your first time
in asia what are your channels it'll be
my first time in asia that's for sure
i've been i've been to switzerland for
for the junior world championships
but uh never to tokyo no okay that's
gonna be amazing for you
one um what does it mean for your family
for you to have achieved this ezra walk
me through when you were able to inform
them that you
got what you wanted out of this it was a
pretty special moment i mean my family
sacrifices a lot
my parents sacrificed a lot my brothers
sacrificed a lot
for me to even you know go after my
dreams in this type of way so
they my parents and my my only my dad
was able to be there at the trials to
see me qualify but my my entire family
was watching back in los angeles so
it was a special moment i facetimed them
after lots of tears
but uh it was it was beautiful it was a
beautiful moment for sure one that i'll
never forget of course
beautiful is a great way to describe it
ezra i wish i could have
seen something like that because i mean
i cannot imagine
um having a child um
look at me at age 11 and say i want to
make the olympics
right i mean if my 11 year old says that
you know obviously my wife would set out
to do whatever we wanted
whatever we could do to make it happen
and then
for you to do it is incredible
i appreciate that thank you it is it is
such a rarity in this world to
to have somebody set out to do it and it
must like i said
i'm i'm so thrilled for you and your
family so um
what about school are are you looking at
colleges right now
ezra yeah yeah i'm looking at colleges
it's summer so i'm trying to forget
about school a little bit
no i'm kidding i'm kidding but uh but no
i i'm looking at college a little bit i
mean i i
i just graduate i just got through
sophomore year so a few more years till
i graduate
okay but uh but yeah taking it day by
day i'm just glad to be in summer and
not have to do schoolwork and training
and then do it all together
okay and uh did i see uh your your
school on your
on some of your shorts on some of these
photographs right here ezra did i see
you
rocking your is it brentwood did i see
you yeah yeah
yeah good eye that is that yeah that is
that
okay well congratulations to you and
everybody in your school and you
represent your school this city of
angels in the united states i'm i'm
getting
just even emotional for you just talking
about it what do you want what do you
want people
uh kids who are 11 years old who might
be sitting
um wherever they're sitting with a
similar
disability and wondering what they
should do
even if i did use the proper word i
don't know if that's the word you'd want
me to use but
no no that's you know yeah okay kids
specifically but you're all good
yeah 100 i mean i think i think one
message i want to get across is like
like the odds can be beat here right
likely the 11 year old that told his
parents that he was going to make the
tokyo 2020 team
the odds were not in my favor and i was
not expected to do that it wasn't likely
for me
to accomplish something like that right
but when you set out to when you set out
to accomplish a goal and you give
everything you have
the odds can be beat and then anything
is truly possible
and uh and so for any kid living with a
physical disability out there
you know who feels like an outsider
feels like they might not fit in
you will find your people and uh if you
set out to accomplish your goal and you
give everything you have the odds can be
beat
just like just like i have and i will
continue to do so so
um you know it's when i feel i feel i i
feel blessed to be
to be born in this time and uh again
given this opportunity to make the us
team this is all a dream for me it's all
a dream come true so
if i can make it happen then anyone can
angelscitysports.org is how people can
get uh
associated with your organization
correct
all right ezra go crush it man thank you
go bring home the gold i'll be looking
out there rooting for you thanks for the
call and let's let's talk uh on the back
end of it regardless of
of uh how you fare or what have you it
doesn't matter
let's check back in with each other okay
100 i appreciate it i appreciate you
having me on
anytime that's uh ezra freck team ezra
05 on twitter and instagram
let's go ezra right here on the rich
island brother man crush it those
parents must be out of their minds
and okay so you've made the olympic team
okay you've started your own
organization
yep do you just basically
call up any school in america say i want
to come and
when can you receive me wait for them to
say yes
i'm assuming his grades are are uh up to
snuff
if they're anything remotely close to
snuff i mean
yeah i've i've started this organization
to help people
um and help people similar to me
and i at age 11 set a goal to make the
olympic team and then i did it
and uh i'd like to come to your school
what
what time can you receive me can you
send a car
can you
can't wait till he goes there then his
name image and likeness deal will be set
right up man thank goodness
good for him age 16 youngest member of
the paralympic team
going to tokyo hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here